هو ليس التشريعا عاديه ويثير جدلا كبيرا
حتى قبل اقراره تشريع جديد لكبح الاضرابات
تنوي الحكومه البريطانيه طرحه لحمايه
الناس وتقليل الاضطراب الذي يصيب سبل
معيشتهم بسبب الاضرابات الواسعه التي تشاد
البلاد وتصف الحكومه اجرائها المرتقبه
بالمعقول كونه يوازن بين حق الاضراب
وممارسه الناس حياتها دون اضطراب كبير
فعله فهي تشير الى قوانين فرنسا واسبانيا
ودول اخرى لم يتم سنها وتطبيها في تلك
البلدان بنفس الطريقه التي تريد الحكومه
اعتمادها هنا كشف الحكومه عن التشريع اثار
رد فعل غضبا من النقابات واحزاب المعارضه
على حد سواء اعتقد ان الحكومه تفهم ما
تفعله فيا تشير الى قوانين فرنسا واسبانيا
ودول الاخرى لم يتم سنها وتطبيها في تلك
البلدان بنفس الطريقه التي تريد الحكو
اعتمادها هنا
سننظر فيما ستقدمه الحكومه ولكن اذا كانت
هناك قيود اضافيه على الاضراب فسنرغيها
والسبب في ذلك هو انني لا اعتقد ان
التشريع هو الطريقه التي تضع بها حد
للنزاعات الصناعيه
الاضرابات في خدمات القطارات والصحه
والتعليم وقوات الحدود احدثت انقساما
واسعا بين مؤيد ومعارض لها وسن قوانين
لحمايه حق العاملين الاخرين غير المضربين
اثار شكوكا في نوايا الحكومه
المقترحه ويبدو ان الحكومه تريد اسكات
المطربين الذين يطالبون بزياده اجورهم
لاعانه اسورهم
عادله ولكن لا يمكن انتاعه حق الناس في
التعبير عن انفسهم وارائهم ويجب ان يكون
هناك نظام لقيام الناس باعمالهم اليوميه
عده اضرابات ستستمر هذا الشهر ابرزها
اضراب الممرضين وفرق الاسعاف وبعض موظف
الحكومه لن يكون من السهل تمرير التشريعات
تحد من الحق الديمقراطي في الادراك مع
التعالي الاصوات لمعارضه لها قبل ترحلها
على النواب وقد تتطلب اشهر من المناقشه في
البرلمانات ثم التصويت عليها قبل ان تصبح
قانونا مصطفى زاروه العربيه